hello and welcome to the you're playing
unti lotto from Finland okay I cannot
resist her go to go back to a kings in
you but sorry for that playing some o c5
okay why this is a position perfectly
him against this closed v5 c 5 center
having castle yet i can go g4 okay yeah
this is mmm close to not playable what
black is doing in i will see what
happens you can always blunder stuff but
then it's an excellent position for wide
let's see um to h4 one even Queen 36 is
interesting just just going in there
let's try that
the reason why this is so questionable
is that the light squares are almost
terminally week mf5 you form they are
fantastic outposts I'm threatening night
at five now and this means that you
cannot play night bg7 for example um so
night f5 or Bishop g5 is also quite
strong and Scott Bishop g5 and group
cheap one
so we have a couple of good options 94
is one of them I can take and go nitey
for us also strong okay let's do it
fantastic night there only four so just
kini too I guess it's very difficult for
him to avoid an ending of a great night
on you for against the rotten bishop on
a fade it will be very difficult
if he takes on g4 you proves my pawn
structure a little bit and then ready to
maybe i should i pay droop g3 this is
probably even stronger okay it's it's
fine okay here i can bring one Knight to
f5 if I want maybe do this first it
could be irritating a no here for night
f5 okay let's do this first yeah i don't
i don't think you will be able to play
the B 5 i'm i'm on this night f5
mm-hmm it's very nice but you're kind of
a little bit overwhelmed with the
possibilities
we go night before he will go be five
and in fact it's not that great hmm
not quite sure what the best
continuation is here ok I'm going back I
think I want to rather prevent you find
age five maybe bring the king over to
see tool so that opening of the
queenside doesn't hurt but what is that
ok I wants to ah i see the point he
wants to take on d5 at the end ok but i
can take with the pawn right what's the
thing then rucca a tour yeah but they
cannot enter I mean is not able to enter
my position here
c4 is also pretty good square
i also have root b 1 and before him it
also makes quite some sense i think i'm
going for that supporting supporting the
pawn preventing night to be 694 now is a
threat as well now d success hanging now
ok only thing I shouldn't do is that's
not blunder the night it would be would
be better where to go tho tho time
morning
yeah just back I guess check
check yeah that is a very good endgame
take it take it that might win actually
but okay it's it's tough now to
calculate it completely should be a
window it's a little bit much check
black resins it to check yeah that is a
very fashionable position out of the
opening so yeah cc5 it's just not a good
idea you have a completely closed center
and after g4 it would be very difficult
here in this setup for black to play a
five he basically um yeah forced it
through immediately but the resulting
position is just excellent for wider if
i was a fantastic square for my night
the bishop is very bad him and yeah
probably I mean I was doing this in
order to use e for wire by this but
probably this is even stronger 495 this
is given as the computers basically
winning for white it's probably stronger
but the position is excellent the way it
is it's just a light squares which are
so weak and they have so many things
that I can attack a couple of options
for sure but white is always keeping a
pretty substantial advantage took it
again no one can just grind away maybe a
row gauge one wasn't even best young
after the way the game went I actually
thought that this this could have been
interesting to just put put pressure on
this pawn and then try to reroute the 92
f five decades it's not so easy to say
you know it was a little bit of
desperation but you just take it end can
be happy in yeah maybe b3 was a bit a
bit easier but it should be so much
better for white in your jack try to be
active but I don't think it it should
ultimately work maybe five is no precise
away this more precise okay the
computers gives a gives a draw here so i
played this badly i should start with e
five and that would actually win and
this this my pawns are a quicker here
you can draw with rugby form i checked
it i thought i have e five yeah but ok
he hasn't really taken on g4 yet of
course so this is actually not winning
this is just the draw we had would have
been disappointing
yeah and it's a draw hmm Wow yeah now
it's it's winning again hmm yeah so
pretty bad technical played area should
have been very clear from here but it
wasn't check and I can start with you
five thank your difference mm okay well
thanks for watching